well we live in the age of woke capital
and that means it's no longer enough for
a company to sell you a product you want
to buy they sell you a worldview whether
you want it or not so Google lectures
about diversity Starbucks tells you
you're a racist and the NBA is no
exception to this rule the league moved
the 2016 all-star game out of North
Carolina for example because of the
state's policy on transgender bathrooms
a policy that the voters of North
Carolina ratified it doesn't matter
NBA players regularly make left-wing
political statements as you know in the
league approves of that but it turns out
there's a limit to freedom of speech
over there in basketball world over the
weekend Houston Rockets general manager
Daryl Morey tweeted support for the
pro-democracy protesters in Hong Kong
now that implied criticism of China's
fascist government and that was too much
for the NBA Maury Street was deleted and
the NBA immediately grovelled to China's
authoritarian American hating leaders
the league issued an apology making it
clear that Maury did not represent the
NRA he may support freedom and democracy
but the NBA certainly does not JD Vance
is the author of hillbilly elegy and one
of the clearest thinkers on modern
politics he joins us tonight
JD what does this tell us about the NBA
and and will capital more generally well
you know tuck her some of the examples
he highlighted Starbucks picking side
with in American politics target picking
side with in American politics you know
these companies positions might be
stupid but they can at least say that
they're choosing the side of an American
political interest in the case of China
whether it's Apple helping the Chinese
security state whether it's Hollywood
bowing down before China or in this case
the NBA bowing down before China you
know these companies can't even claim
that they're defending an American value
or an American interest and I think one
of the things that tells us is that
American business interests if they see
the almighty dollar in the hands of a
foreign rival they'll go and chase it
even if it's not in the best interest in
their own country I'm not in the best
interest I mean this is our preeminent
rival a enemy actually I think from
their perspective on the world stage a
country that's about to overtake us
economically and militarily I mean
siding with them seems like a profound
betrayal it's a profound betrayal in a
couple of different ways Tucker the the
first is what you mentioned I mean I
think we're in a geopolitical struggle
with China unlike anything we've seen
since at least the early 1930s with
Germany we're not yet at physical war
and hopefully of course we don't ever go
to war with China but we're gonna
struggle really for global preeminence
with this country and they have
ambitions to be a global superpower that
is necessarily going to take them in
competition with us you know the other
way that this is a really significant
betrayal of American values is that
China actively does so many of the
things that the left says that it hates
about our own country you want to talk
about Islamic persecution the Chinese
are running actual concentration camps
for some of its Islamic population in
China you want to talk about treating
gender minorities fairly which is the
favorite topic of the left these days go
to go try to find a transgender bathroom
in China go try to find a to gender
bathroom in the state of China they're
actively doing things that people in
this country say that they hate and
violate their political beliefs of
course you know when Republicans do it
it's the target of criticism but when
the Chinese do it
people seem to be okay with the
violation of core values and of course
Tucker as you probably know the most
egregious hypocrisy on this front is
climate change if you actually buy the
argument that co2 emissions are causing
global climate change the worst offender
by far today and in the future is China
there is a reason the climate change
activists go after Americans and
American consumers but they don't go
after China and it makes it pretty clear
that it has nothing to do with climate
change it has to do with frankly taking
the side of a really vile regime over
the interests of our own country and
they know that we're so self-hating that
they can control us they can bully us
into submission but the Chinese don't
hate themselves do they know they don't
Tucker and that's one of the craziest
things about China is is whether it's
Chinese nationals who are living
overseas in America or Western Europe
whether it's folks who maybe go on a
student visa and then come
what's pretty clear is that China is
very good at ensuring that its own
citizens actually love the country and I
don't think there's a whole lot that's
especially loveable about the Chinese
nation these days but they're very good
at making their own citizens patriotic
and unfortunately we have a country that
has a lot to be you know we have a lot
to be proud of in America yes but
unfortunately a lot of folks don't think
that this country is something to be
proud of and when you have when you're
in a global geopolitical struggle where
one nation is afraid of its own shadow
and the other nation is proud of itself
it's not too difficult to imagine which
which nation is going to win and I think
I think because of this sucker just just
one really important point in all this
is that we have to be willing to push
back against this stuff using political
power you know I'm a Republican but one
of the things I don't like about the
Republican Party these days is that
we're afraid of actually using political
power there are things that we could do
to push back against these companies
that are taking the side of China over
America right and the camera in the NBA
we could go after their stadium
subsidies but what happened last time we
had significant political power the very
same companies that are taking the side
of China over Americans and American
consumers got a big tax break we can't
keep doing this we can't keep shooting
ourselves in the foot it's masochism and
it's terrible for the country I couldn't
agree more
Katy Vance it's always great to hear
from you thank you very much thanks